during infection by HIV three enzymes
play essential roles in the lifecycle of
the virus reverse transcriptase
integrase and protease the first enzyme
HIV reverse transcriptase copies the
viral RNA genome by combining individual
host nucleotides to build a
complementary DNA strand when reverse
transcriptase finishes this strand it
will replace the original viral RNA with
another DNA strand forming a DNA double
helix the second enzyme HIV integrase
inserts the viral DNA into the cell's
DNA
the third enzyme HIV protease is needed
at the last steps of the viral life
cycle to cut the HIV poly protein into
its individual functional parts HIV
enzymes are targets for drug therapy two
types of drugs block reverse
transcriptase drugs like AZT mimic the
normal building blocks of DNA but
prematurely terminate the DNA chain
drugs like nevirapine bind on the
backside of reverse transcriptase
distorting the enzyme so that it can no
longer perform its DNA building reaction
while tegra veer binds to to magnesium
ions in integrase that are essential for
the DNA integration reaction drugs likes
aquinnah beer mimic the proteins cut by
HIV protease blocking maturation of the
virus drug resistance is a major problem
for HIV drug therapy for instance when
patients are treated with drugs that
block HIV protease most of the viruses
are destroyed but rare mutant forms of
the virus survive
these mutant viruses make a mutated form
of the protease this protease resists
the binding of drugs but can still cut
the viral polyprotein over many
generations the population of viruses
builds up additional mutations that
further resist the drug
the most effective current treatment
method uses a combination of drugs that
attack the different enzymes so that
some of the drugs will still be active
even if one of the enzymes becomes
resistant